have you ever wondered why we find
action films so compelling to watch
especially if you don't consider
yourself to be a violent person why is
it so satisfying to watch someone dodge
a kick throw a punch knock a guy out and
then jump out of the window of an
exploding building likewise why do we
enjoy watching dance so much well
understanding these mechanisms can help
to shed a little bit of light on the way
that the human brain actually works and
it also shows us how we can use
visualization to train in techniques
almost as effectively as if we were
actually practicing them for real so to
understand this we firstly to rewind a
little bit and look at how the brain
handles any kind of movement so movement
is generally controlled by the motor
cortex this is a brain region located
around here at the top and it's
essentially mapped pretty much
one-to-one with different parts of your
body so you have parts of your motor
cortex that represent your hands parts
represent your feet your neck your
tongue and the size of these regions
depends on how sensitive and how
articulate those areas are if you have
to stimulate individual neurons within
the motor cortex this would cause those
parts your body either to move or for
you to feel sensation in those areas so
when we make any movement first the
necessary region of the motor cortex
lights up that sends the signal down our
bodies and we make the movement but the
motor cortex doesn't work entirely on
its own it also is supported by various
other brain regions including the
cerebrum the basal ganglia and the
premotor cortex and the supplementary
motor cortex and the one we're
interested in is the premotor cortex
because in here we see activity prior to
a movement this is where you prepare for
a movements and areas within that part
of the brain light up prior to the same
areas respectively in the motor cortex
lighting up and this is how we visualize
a movement before you make any movement
you first visualize it and if you think
back you're probably actually
consciously aware of this to some degree
so if you're going to go and throw a
ball at a wall and then try and catch it
you'll predict the trajectory of that
ball you'll feel yourself do it prior to
doing it you'll feel the movement how
you should move and then that's kind of
preparing your body for that movement
before it's sent over to the motor
cortex and down and your supplementary
motor cortex does things like helping
you with you
balance and with spatial awareness etc
there's lots more going on but basically
the premotor cortex is for planning and
visualization and then the motor cortex
is for execution so we go to make a
movement we visualize the movement first
and then we execute on it and we perform
it if our visualization was correct and
the movement goes the way we want it to
then we get the release of positive
hormones and the reward hormones like
dopamine and that strengthens the neural
connections that caused that movement
and that visualization of that movement
so when we predict something correctly
reward hormones are released and we feel
good about it because that makes us more
like to make that movement again next
time or more likely to predict the
movement of something else
correctly next time when we get it wrong
then we don't get that release because
it was wrong and the brain doesn't want
to enforce that belief or that behavior
so this is how we learn to walk we stand
up we fall off balance we hurt ourselves
so we don't do that again we do it
slightly differently we get it right we
put a foot forward don't fall over the
brain releases dopamine and that neural
connection is slightly strengthened and
over time our movement improves over and
over more and more and we develop that
physics model as well and this is why
visualization training works this is why
you can improve your ability say in a
dance routine or a martial arts form or
cutter not by necessarily having to
practice it in person or just by
visualizing it by imagining yourself
doing it when you do that brain areas
are lighting up in your brain in the
premotor cortex just as though you're
making those movements for real and as
we know neurons that fire together wire
together so it doesn't matter to your
brain but you're not actually engaging
in that action as far as its concerned
you pretty much are those neurons are
firing and you're forming those
connections which will help you to
improve your technique this also helps
us in the gym if you're struggling with
your squatting form or your deadlift you
can visualize yourself doing it and
really feel yourself going through the
motion as though you're actually doing
it and that will help to strengthen the
connections which will improve your
performance and your technique when you
actually go to do it for real of course
you have to be somewhat careful here
because if you're practicing it
incorrectly in your brain then this can
lead to negative plasticity that means
brain plasticity the formation of new
neural connections but not for a
positive end for an actually negative
end it's actually making you worse at
performing that particular
technique and recent research shows us
that we don't only predict our own
movements in these parts of the brains
but also the movements of things around
us the trajectory of projectiles for
instance or if we were to throw an
object we predict how that object moves
so if you're imagining throwing a ball
you don't just imagine how you need to
move your arm you then predict the
movement of that ball through space you
watch it bounce off the wall and come
back to you so in other words we have an
inbuilt physics engine that we run no
doubt learned through years and years of
interactions with our real world so if
you're somebody throws a lot of balls
you become better at predicting the
movement of those balls the weight the
feel and thus you become more accurate
when you're throwing and catching and we
even have our own theory of mind
involved here theory of mind is our idea
of how other people will think and
behave and studies show it's missing in
people with autism and very young
children but as we grow up in the normal
healthy development brain we learn the
way that other people react to our
actions become better at predicting that
my advantage is rage incoming assault
feral experience so if you're
visualizing a fight for instance you not
only have to predict how you're gonna
move you have to predict how the
opponent is going to move and that's the
limitation of visualization training
because you can predict how you're gonna
move you can perform the action you can
learn a cat or a dance routine but you
can't necessarily predict precisely how
the weights gonna move how that's going
to feel how the balls going to move or
how an opponent will throw punches at
you
so visualization training is useful to
an extent and whilst it could
potentially increase the mind muscle
connection muscle fiber recruitment I
don't know about that it certainly won't
cause muscle fiber tears it won't cause
the build-up of metabolites you're not
gonna get strongly you're not gonna
build muscle by lying in bed imagining
going to the gym you'll just might
improve your technique what's even more
fascinating about all this and what
you'll already know if you watch my
video on it embodied cognition is that
we also use the same process to
understand words that people say to us
things are happening in the world around
us everything really
because when song talks to you you have
to translate that into meaning in your
brain we have different languages but
obviously there's a kind of base code of
the brain how do we understand something
how do we turn words
into meaning that we can act on we can
think of this a little bit like a
computer code you type in basic in
Python in Java in C but the computer
converts that into machine code binary
in order to actually act on it in order
for it to have a physical impact on that
machine so how the words have an impact
on our brain but for a while
psychologists didn't know and they just
called it mental ease they called that
the the arbitrary base code of the brain
but now the ruling theory is something
called embodied cognition this is the
idea that we understand things because
we visualize them so when someone talks
to me and tells me that they went for a
run I actually visualize a person going
for a run or I even visualize myself
running I can feel what it's like to run
when someone says something's cold my
body experiences that cold by
visualizing it and there is evidence to
show that this is probably what's
happening when someone talks to you
brain scans show that the relevant areas
in your brain light up as though that
thing were happening to you so our
understanding of abstract concepts like
maths and programming even those things
are probably based on our interactions
with the world around us for instance
maths is based on our idea of quantity
which we learn through interactions with
the world so what does all this have to
do with action and watching things
explode well this comes down to the
action of mirror neurons so mirror
neurons are neurons that fire when we
see someone else
experience something or make a movement
so in studies monkeys have watched other
monkeys using their hands to grasp
things and whilst they were observing
that behavior they were having brain
scans and they saw that in the premotor
cortex of those monkeys the observer
monkeys the same patterns of activity
was seen as would be expected in the
monkey that was actually moving so in
other words when we see something happen
we visualize it we feel it that's why we
cringe when we watch someone who's in a
very embarrassing situation that's why
we wince when we see someone get hurt
and yeah basically it's probably the
foundation of most of our social
interactions so what happens when you
watch Jackie Chan kick someone over a
bridge well on the one hand you feel
yourself as there you're kicking the
person over the bridge and on the other
hand you feel as though you're falling
off a bridge and at the same time you're
observing the physics of everything
that's happening when you see a building
explode you're observing the physics
of everything that's happening so this
is actually improving our mental model
of movement both for ourselves and for
objects in the world it's causing brain
plasticity so when we're watching
someone fight or when we're watching
something explode we're visualizing it
and we're feeling it so it's really
happening
and at the same time our brain is
learning from that it's predicting how
that movements going to be and then it's
rewarding us if we get it right and it's
letting go of that if we get it wrong
this is how computer games work with
taught a particular set of inputs will
result in a reward if we get it
perfectly right
dopamine if we get it slightly wrong no
dopamine and that kind of instant
feedback loop is what makes it so
addictive and the same thing happens
when we watch a dance we see people
moving beautifully we predict the
trajectory we feel as though we're doing
it and we feel as though we're dexterous
and as they we have got that kind of
amazing spatial awareness and because
that's a positive desirable trait we're
learning through observation and our
brain is releasing those positive
neurotransmitters and hormones that we
find so great so good feelings so
addictive so we now know that we can
visualize training in order to get
better at something and in theory it
also means that observing other people
engaging in the behavior will make us
better at that behavior so if you love
bodybuilding watch loads of YouTube
channels watch loads of videos of people
performing deadlifts and bench presses
if you love fighting then watch people
fight if you love dance then watch
people dance you'll ingrain it more and
more just by watching it and you should
become better at performing it yourself
but do be aware that we're all
differently built you'll have different
limb lengths will have different
strengths and weaknesses and physics
varies a lot depending on the weight of
objects so of course there's limitations
here again and you can miss learn
through observation - so that's why you
like watching Jackie Chan punch someone
and jump out an exploding building
because you're learning you're learning
how someone will react to that movement
and you're learning how physics work on
a grand scale that results in a massive
dopamine release and hopefully it
improves your own ability in sports so
thanks a ton for watching guys I hope
you found something useful and
interesting if you did then please leave
a like please comment down below let me
know what your favorite action scenes
are it's got to turn more like this on
the way on fitness bodybuilding
performance brain training productivity
working online so if that sounds
great then let me know in the comments
what you'd like to see next or more of
and thanks once again tonnes for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
for now